the Solus project is a first person
survival adventure game set on a
deserted alien planet unlike most other
survival games the Solus project is not
a sandbox game with an open world but
rather a more traditional linear
single-player experience with some
survival elements as an experience it's
similar to traditional shooters there's
a linear path through the world with ten
large and complex levels to play through
the story goes that you crash land on an
alien planet every other member of your
crew is dead while exploring the Barons
surroundings you find out that you are
not the first intelligent being to have
set foot here you stumble upon
megalithic buildings similar to ancient
buildings on earth and strangely enough
remains of what appear to be human like
aliens who were they and what brought
about their demise the experience we're
after is one of intense isolation so
this is Latin for a loan the planet is
deserted your crew are dead all of the
aliens on the planet appear to be as
well there are no animals and no life in
general it is totally deserted you are
light-years from any human contact and
there are no other ships that can come
to your rescue if that weren't bad
enough mankind is on the verge of
extinction and you were supposed to be
the last hope for finding a safe haven
to set up a colony now here you are
crash-landed on a small island utterly
isolated utterly alone yet the faith of
mankind rests with you you have no
choice but to survive
you